ici nous avons tout en fait les
vêtements les meubles
il ya des produits pour la cuisine pour
la vie quotidienne
valentina elena dans ce qui sera bientôt
leur future maison en quelques jours à
beignon un élan de solidarité s'est
improvisé les gens du coin ont déposé
des dons et c'est dominique qui a trouvé
la location pour elle une autre jeune
femme et leurs enfants
dans luz on pouvait être allongée par
terre quelque part vivre je ne sais pas
dans la salle de sport et là on a une
maison c'est impressionnant c'est là
elles sont arrivés dimanche en bretagne
après trois jours de train depuis leur
ville denis pro en ukraine si dominique
les a prises en charge c'est qu'il est
leur cousin par alliance sa famille
russo ukrainienne le couple vivait
jusqu'ici le conflit avec inquiétude
mais par procuration et puis de là bas
un cousin a passé un appel au secours il
a fallu passer à l'acte et sergei nous
dit voilà j'ai ma femme
tu es cousine les cinq petits enfants
qui sont cachés dans un bunker sauf que
les conditions du vainqueur seront
devienne catastrophique on entend les
bombes est-ce que tu acceptes de prendre
en charge la famille
non mais ils sont restés en ukraine pour
défendre le pays on a passé à travers le
pays qui est bombardé donc on a eu très
peur parce que à chaque moment on
on aurait pu être tué mais après avoir
passé la frontière c'est tout on a
compris que nous sommes en sécurité que
nous sommes protégés maintenant à
beignon la solidarité va se poursuivre
pour faciliter l'intégration ce week-end
une rencontre avec la population sera
organisé et l'inde il les enfants seront
accueillis à l'école je pense que
sincèrement ils ont vécu un vrai
traumatisme moi je pense en particulier
aux ses cinq enfants faut essayer de de
les projeter vers autre chose tout en
sachant qu'ils n'arriveront pas à
oublier ceux qui viennent de traverser
et puis pour valentina ses cousines
dominique à trouver du travail il est
chef d'entreprise ça facilite les choses
il veut qu'elle retrouve un début d'
équilibre qu'elle ne reste pas seulement
suspendu aux nouvelles du front